what the hell is this this Morty is my
archive of all the experiences you
begged me to remove from your life lest
you go insane I have so much fun making
it I was like those characters are
really fun to do the voices of I'm
talking back and forth like that it just
felt good I was like this this feels
really really fun
it was the RIC voice for the grandpa it
was the Morty voice for the young kid it
was sort of eventually gonna happen that
those two voices were gonna end up in
something because they were really
strong
I called him Morty's mind blowers and
we'll be doing this instead of
interdimensional cable lemongrab was I
had a podcast that I did with Brian
Ridley and Jackie Bruce Kirino called
grandma's virginity podcast and pen Ward
was like a fan of it and pen created
Adventure Time we had him on an episode
and I I remember after that he wanted to
he asked me to do a voice I didn't know
what it was but I was like yeah of
course I'd love to do a voice on a bench
of time because I loved the show
they sent me the boards the storyboards
for the episode and I looked through it
and I didn't really know what to do so I
went in and I just started screaming and
he's like that's the things like that's
it great I learned the limits of my
voice with that character for sure
I blew my voice out really bad then Tom
Kenny told me to go to this this really
good ENT and I had to get a cortisone
shot and not talk for like two weeks
literally not talk ideas of app called
talk bot and I would talk to people
using the app text-to-speech and it then
the app started really depressing so
every time I would text something people
would be like are you okay because it'd
be like I want sandwiches just be really
everything I would say which sounds sad
and that voice is actually the voice we
ended up using for the butter robot and
Rick and Morty that exact app because we
in the Edit Bay that was around the time
in the Edit Bay where I was using that
app all the time I couldn't do Morty's
voice for a while after that adventure
time the the third episode of Lemongrab
it was really crazy also I'm not just
weirdly petting my lap I have a I have
my best friend here one of my best
friends I've got to but this is one of
them isn't that right little pup pup yes
gravity falls Hersh wanted me to do a
voice and he wasn't quite sure what
character so I kind of came in a couple
times and took a crack at a few
different characters and it didn't stick
and then the blendin voice was sort of
the one that felt like it worked just
sound like Morty like oh man come on
geez you know like it but it sounded
deeper like more like my voice it was
like I'm blendin blandin I'm you know it
was more like that and Morty's like huh
come on Rick you're gonna suffocate me
here you're suffocating me I don't want
to do this you know like a lot of my
voices just sound like that it's pretty
sad I don't have a lot of range I more
I'm more just played into the kind of
nervousness and anxiousness that he was
sort of dealing with because he had a
lot of running shoulders so it's just
leaned into that there wasn't really
anybody in my life that I drew for but I
don't really do that ever
there's no real there's no real deep you
know like I'm not sitting there
meditating and like
creating image boards and I'm just I
just going into it you know like I don't
know physics so there's a really
interesting story with that I was at
Disney working with Alex Hirsch on that
show we were developing it together we
had cast someone else as the voice of
Oscar I don't even I wasn't even a part
of this I just remember I was there late
and Eric Coleman grabbed me who's the
head of TV animation and he's like hey
can you go in and just record this
character from top to bottom I don't
know they had some sort of emergency
with the with with the audio that they
had from the person that they had cast
and so I was like okay and so I went and
I just did the voice for the little
pilot presentation and then that went
out the next morning
- I'm blanking on his name but he's
right below Bob Iger and I can't
remember his name but he was like oh
yeah but this is great the voices are
all great this is awesome and so I was
sort of like does that mean does that
mean I'm doing the voice of this
character or what like what's going on
they didn't really tell me but I sort of
assumed I think I'm doing the voice of
this character and then of course time
went on and I I took a job writing on
the show mainly just because I didn't
want to get recast I was like if I'm
around
they won't recast me I just I was
waiting for the other shoe to drop on
that and it didn't happen so yeah I
ended up doing that character it wow I
guess one could say that you and I make
sweet music together Oscar was more just
more innocent you know like I mean it's
a Disney cartoon so obviously that's the
innocence is sort of built in he was
gentler I think very moral Oscar was
just like a limp and limp noodle nerd
you know really easy to push around and
like bottom-feeder kind of character and
I learned that crocheting is a fun
leisure activity for a fish of any
gender I made you both sweater vest
Oscar is kind of OCD if I recall
correctly like he's very like neurotic
I think Oscar was a bit more like he had
more neuroses going on
oh that's a throwback here yeah I did a
bunch of cartoons
oh she dumped the mic I did a bunch of
cartoons for Sarah across the seasons
and like I mean that was my job for a
while it's just I was on location at the
studio with my friends and we were just
writing and animating cartoons there and
I was grabbing the cast of the show to
come to voices like in between scenes
and stuff it was really really cool I
was a really fun time I did a cartoon
called cookie party for Sarah and we did
a few episodes of it and God it was
really funny man it was like I it was
the concept was this guy named Michael
who makes cookies so good that they come
alive they want him to eat him really
bad all the cookies want to be eaten by
him but they but he he's kind of
overweight he's trying to he's really
trying to like watch himself so he
doesn't want it he just can't eat them I
love that all the delicious cookies I
baked come alive and play with me but
sometimes I really wish I could share
you with other people no we won't let
other people eat us we only want you to
eat us
we love you Michael and then there's
this bad guy who's who wants to know how
he make makes cookies oh so good that
they come alive and he's coming around
and he builds a robot cookie named
Proteus it's [ __ ] bonkers but it but
we I think we did two or three episodes
of that and I was like I [ __ ] love
that I was I was like I would do I would
do a lot more episodes of this if if the
opportunity had presented itself I would
have been like let's roll with this you
know but those are deep cuts if you can
dig them up I don't know where they are
Gary on small foot that was weird
I don't even know how that happened it
was just like hey do you want to do this
voice for this movie okay yeah that's
that sounds good and I went and I was
there for like an hour or less than an
hour I just like I'm a the guys
sprinkled throughout the movie but he's
got like you know that if you take all
the lines and squish them together it's
like you could say I'm in under three
minutes you know what I mean so we just
kind of jumped to the scenes and I
80-yard it was really cool I was like in
a giant mixing room with like a huge
movie theater
screen doing that doing that stuff that
was really cool that was similar to when
I did for Michael Dougherty in Krampus I
did one of the little cookies but that
was the same experience it was a giant
like soundstage with a I guess when they
do movies they just like hey let's mix
it in a in extravagant massive cube room
with a movie theater screen cuz like we
don't do Rick and Morty that way we did
the pilot that way but and I was like
this is [ __ ] unnecessary but alright
and then we stopped doing that I started
mixing it like you know normal people
would do with Gary they just said they
wanted him to just be kind of nervous
and panicked it was really just working
with them to find the voice like that's
the boring answer but it's true it was
like okay like this like yeah no no a
little bit more like freaked out you
know whatever and then I got it kind of
okay that's okay then that's it they
like that okay I'll just I'll just keep
doing that people need to start casting
me on these [ __ ] big-budget animated
movies right I mean like listen to my
process it's it's like oh what do you
guys want you want okay like this and
then BOOM all right we got it let's roll
let's do this thing
and I'm real friendly and nice and stuff
I mean I don't know what's going on no
I'm kidding I'm not I'm not auditioning
for anything that's why I should be I'm
too busy but but if somebody comes to me
hey yeah I'll be in the next sharks
movie come on
Katzenberg is he still no no what stream
works is that Katzenberg he's got kwibi
now what is he still got a foot and
DreamWorks
what does DreamWorks anyways whatever
Disney no Disney's I'm not - I did
Disney but I don't know if they would
put me back on Disney up - I'm too edgy
am I am I too edgy I don't know I'm too
edgy maybe but come on Disney put me in
the next princess movie as like to care
it you know I'm the carrot
I'm the carrot in this [ __ ] movie you
know let's sing a song ba doo dee doo
I'm a carrot in this Disney movie make a
toy out of me you know
anyway Krampus I'm friends with Michael
Dougherty he's he's one of the best
people I've ever met in my life he's
incredible and he like I has a deep love
for horror and and I think his style and
in the way he approaches horror is
fantastic and but anyways yeah he just
texted me and he's like hey come and do
this voice cuz it was just a fun little
monster gremlin guy just screaming and
then it got pitched way up I remember
thinking I don't think anyone's gonna
know that to me yeah it's like you
cannot tell I mean which is fine I was
like a at the point of it was just like
oh this is cool like to put you in here
it'll be fun but um that was probably
the least like okay let's we got to
really sit down and talk about this
character who they are you know it
wasn't that none of that
like it was pitched up and you know and
Seth Green did one of them who I'm
friends with as well
that's how I met Michael was through
Seth but uh sorry it sounds like I'm
[ __ ] named her I'm like oh let me
pick up these names I keep dropping
Jesus Christ man hump up up it's a
problem on it's a problem right now
chubby Weber's that was my voice my
friend Brian Wisel I really wanted him
to have a show I was like you gotta have
a show because I just want more of your
weird stuff so I helped him get this
show on Adult Swim and called hot
streets it's funny I feel like I did the
voice for him at one point cuz we're
pretty good friends we hang out a lot
and I think it was just like do that
same thing like do that for the show you
know anything for this dog the funny
thing about that character is that there
would be screwed in the script I would
get a script and there would be like
scripted dialogue for this dog like if
the line was like okay you guys I'm
gonna go get the keys for the car and
then I would be like you know what I
mean like that kind of like the Scooby
Doo kind of but whiney and mumbled and
stuff I will say that the scripts in
some cases they definitely motivated
like the energy like oh he needs to be
really sad or he needs to be [ __ ]
pissed or or panicked or whatever so but
it was just funny that they took the
time to write these these these lines of
dialogue that no one would ever hear
Rick and Morty I'm just checking him for
flea as well we do this but uh Rick and
Morty I mean they were inspired by Back
to the Future I did a cartoon that's
really disgusting on purpose called
the real animated adventures of doc and
Marty I think is what it was called I
was gonna call it the real animated Back
to the Future I was gonna try to get
really like let's get a cease and desist
kind of energy on it because I had done
house of Cosby's and Bill Cosby came
after me and I thought I just thought
that was so [ __ ] weird that Bill
Cosby's lawyers would be busy concerned
about a little cartoon I was so [ __ ]
weird so I thought I'm gonna try doing
that again I'm gonna make a really
shocking offensive like animated cartoon
and and I've been doing those voices so
I'll just do I'll just do those voices
for it it's the only way to fix our time
travel [ __ ] your saliva needs to be warm
and fresh and it must be administered by
your tongue Marty it was also for
channel 101 and I wanted part of me was
thinking I want to hear a audience of
people screaming like and covering
seeing them cover their eyes and just go
oh god so that was sort of the
motivation behind it was like it was
intentionally disgusting I'm confused
Marty trust me like that was the point I
was like it wasn't like oh yeah this is
my art man like this is what I do
this is Who I am it wasn't that at all
it was like it was like we knew what we
were making it was like this is [ __ ]
horrible it's so horrible I have so much
fun making it and I was like those
characters are really fun to do the
voices of talking back and forth like
that it just felt good I was like this
this feels really really fun and so I
started figuring out other ways I could
incorporate those characters into things
I mean I put him in everything I liked
those voices anyways I was doing Rick
and Morty voices and all the Fox pilots
like in just different characters and I
done a bunch more doc and Marty stuff
for channel 101 that's also really
[ __ ] horrible on purpose I knew that
they were really strong and interesting
so I just kind of kept going in that
direction and I was building all kinds
of projects around those voices then Dan
Harmon called me one day and he's like
okay these characters are [ __ ]
amazing and all the crazy sheep you want
to do is great but let's build a sturdy
frame around it
let's put put a family let's make them
related so it says grant its mortise
grandpa that really made the show way
more broad way more grounded and just I
believe it's why this show has gotten as
big as it is you know solar opposites
was originally an idea I had for channel
101 or acceptable TV actually acceptable
TV was a sketch show that me and Dan and
a bunch of the channel 101 people had on
vh1 for a brief moment during the era of
like flava flava Flav's love castle and
you know new york's Love Machine house
or whatever but anyway so it's during
that era and I pitched this thing that
was just to aliens it was live-action
and it was to aliens on earth and they
were here for some kind of mission they
had like a supreme leader that they
talked to at the beginning and end like
a briefing and a debriefing of whatever
their mission was for that episode it
was gonna be live-action with these
weird paper mache heads and we were
gonna put like in post in after-effects
like the 3d mouth and eyes on them and
the idea was they are like the odd
couple of aliens
so his solar opposites brilliant and so
gonna be the odd couple it was very
underdeveloped back then it was just
like an idea and I pitched it and it
didn't get any traction and then I just
kind of forgot about it I had a deal at
Fox xx and so I had kind of gone through
three other show ideas with them are two
other show ideas sorry and I was on like
the last one and it was sort of like
okay if they don't like this then I'm
out I'm out of the I'm out of the
contract and so I got my buddy Mike
McMahan who who I've known forever and
who worked on it was working on Rick and
Morty at the time cuz I was like I can't
I've tried two pitches on my own and I
don't want to do this by myself anymore
like it was just like it's not it's too
much so I was like let's do this
together if you want to and let's come
up with something so we just started
brainstorming ideas in between seasons
two and three of Rick and Morty is when
this happened
and then I was like well
okay well I do have a thing from a long
time ago that's pretty much a blank
canvas called solar opposites that could
be pretty fun and it's just aliens on
earth and we reworked it because
originally it was going to be the same
as the old idea which is there on earth
observing humans and reporting back to
the to the homeworld but then we
realized I think it's a lot better if
their homeworlds completely destroyed
and they're stranded on earth it's a bit
more of like a Gilligan's Island but the
primary objective was like let's come up
with something that we can just have a
lot of fun and do a bunch of crazy sheep
let's just build some characters that
will be really fun to write and voice so
we we leaned into the idea of you know
the opposite the opposite side eeeh
obviously like Corvo who's the button
down like serious don't around you know
kind of character I play that I play him
we may be trapped on this world on the
brink of mass extinction plagued by a
species that destroys the environment
but at least we have each other and then
Thomas Middleditch plays Terry who is
the he's just so obsessed with Earth
culture human culture like everything
anime Pokemon football video games
movies Gossip Girl I mean just anything
the Kardashians and then Corvo sort of
sees humanity as like a virus on the
planet which it's true polluting the
planet destroying it creating a
texas-sized trash island in the middle
of the ocean that's a real thing I think
I don't know maybe it's not real maybe
we're being lied to about everything
maybe we're living in a simulation but
anyways Corvo is just like humans are
[ __ ] horrible the air is polluted all
the stupid makeup is dumb and we're in a
waste of time like our art our video
games our movies then as the show
progresses he there are things that he
can get kind of sucked into I probably
oversold the idea that he doesn't like
Earth culture because he just doesn't he
doesn't like humans and he's more
crotchety and more he's got his guard up
he doesn't want to [ __ ] like anything
but then sometimes he does and it's like
for grudgingly he'll end up getting
really into some like magic we have an
episode where he gets way into magic
there's a motive for him to
do it like he's got an ulterior motive
for getting into magic but at first he's
gonna hates it he hates magic and then
he kind of starts to it's like this big
grudging like oh I mean at it's at its
core the show is you know a family of
aliens that are living amongst humans
and then you just get to see them
they're almost like immigrants it's like
an immigrant story where they're they're
just trying to understand humanity and
they're very confused about certain
things that we take for granted and
understand and there's a lot of humor to
be had there but then there's also they
have access to this like their ship is
filled with all kinds of crazy
futuristic sci-fi so they're they're
kind of they're getting into a lot of
trouble they're solving a lot of their
problems with technology that we've
never heard of as humans that caused a
lot of problems on the show and there's
a lot of fun there oh don't throw that
out I can sell it it has an unstable
grey hole inside you weren't unstable
claims and then we just kind of follow
you know those characters doing doing
their little odds and ends it's really
exciting a really exciting show
all right GQ I guess that's enough
rambling for me I'm in my trash bunker
safe for now from the coronavirus so
hopefully you guys stay safe too and you
know watch out for the economy collapse
it's coming up by a Bitcoin and crypto I
don't know maybe don't do that all right
bye